[Music]
what's going on guys you know I think we
can all agree the Oscars happened the
most glamorous night in Tinseltown and
that means one thing it's time for the
grouchy's so the Oscars you know they
were kind of boring and predictable
there was no big adele dazeem moment you
remember John Travolta no moonlight
la-la-land Best Picture screw up so just
like Jimmy Kimmel tried to introduce a
little bit of drama with his jet ski
giveaway we are gonna be responding to
anyone who retweets this video on
Twitter with this photo of me Hal
Rudnick photoshopped onto a jet ski hey
come on we're doing our best guys on
with the show the first grouchy is the
what's his deal Ward the winner
Shane vo part of the production design
team for the shape of water look at this
guy what's his deal like did he leave
his jacket and the dryer for two longer
arms why does one do that and he's
wearing some fresh kicks and he's got
the shades it hey Shane what's your deal
ooh this one is a grouchy's classic the
BuzzFeed gif of the Night award the
nominees Jennifer Garner's mind-melting
guillermo del toro double-checking that
Best Picture envelope and the winner
Denzel slyly checking his watch times up
is an important movement and it's also
what Denzel and I were thinking as the
show entered our number three next up
the maybe you should have hosted a ward
Kimmel did a fine job but he got a
little bit upstaged by some people on
his own show
the nominees Maya Rudolph and Tiffany
Haddish
Jodie Foster and j-law and the winner
kemal Nanjiani dude at some of the
biggest laughs of the night while
presenting and summed up basically the
spirit of the show in just a few badass
lines some of my favorite movies are
movies by straight white dudes about
straight white dudes now straight white
dudes can watch movie starring me and
you relate to that it's not that hard
I've done it my whole life
how about Nanjiani for Oscar host 2019
let's start that hashtag get it trending
now it's time for the Berenstein bears
Mandela effect award Mitch reference
look it up this award is for proof that
we are all living in an alternate
dimension winner Matthew McConaughey
Academy Award winner Matthew McConaughey
its McConaughey right I mean it's a Mack
honest Anse so then it could be either I
mean I've always heard hey but he's a he
so maybe it's Makani
look up that reference this one here is
the it's canon now award the award for
the thing that once said is forever Star
Wars Canon the nominees Luke Skywalker
and Wonder Woman existing in the same
universe the Jedi pension plan I'm also
here to pick up my monthly check under
the Jedi pension plan and the winner
bb-8 is Jewish how do you always know
what bb-8 is saying I'm fluent in
Yiddish I always knew bb-8 was
circumsized look I am
up next the LA elitists award the part
of the show where the good folks of Los
Angeles look down their noses at
everybody else and break their own arms
baton themselves on the back the
nominees basketball or Kobe Bryant
getting an Oscar because he played for
the LA Lakers the 405 freeway movie
getting an Oscar because it has 405 in
the title and the winner
millionaire celebrities in tuxedos
shooting hot dogs at the filthy
groveling masses
put a sandwich in your stupid mouth hoes
well you'll watch a wrinkle in time you
cretins we could invite you to enjoy the
rest of the Oscars when it's just watch
the rest of the movie we just
interrupted and ruined for you Oh
straighten up it's the best tie award
the award for the best tie of the night
the nominees Gael Garcia Bernal Mexican
flag tie Timothy shall amaze classic
white bowtie and the winner
everyone's Oscar pool when the favorites
win in every category you know I'm
talking allison janney gary oldman
everyone wins
exactly the amount that they put in
except for that one weirdo who actually
watched all the documentary shorts
Trevor
you're weird whoa here we go it's the
finally award and this award goes to
cinematographer Roger Deakins breaking a
longer drought than DiCaprio to win a
well-deserved Oscar he was not many in
14 times he shot Sicario No Country for
Old Men Skyfall so many great films and
dude finally gets the chance to speak
and he seems like a really cool guy to
maybe have a beer with and now that
Roger and Leo of their Oscars the eyes
of the world now turn to Amy Adams the
official new Oscar snubby who move that
cursor to the search bar it's the let
Google do it award for the moment the
show we all had to Google the winner
Frances McDormand giving us two words I
have two words to leave with you tonight
ladies and gentlemen inclusion writer is
it a movie is it a band is it a Karma
Sutra position either way all of America
had to go google it
thanks Frances McDormand to be fair not
the worst thing anyone's asked me to
Google beam at you one percenters it's
time for the 99% their award this is the
award for that moment where we were so
close to ending the show without a hitch
but then the whole thing derails and the
winner is J miles Dale producer of the
shape of water this
he was trying to give a speech and then
Jimmy Kimmel comes in trying to give
away a jet ski and things got all wiki
wacky ah guys remember I've got
something to say say it before del Toro
because del Toro is gonna suck up the
rest of the time and take it to jetski
town sorry J miles Dale at least you got
yourself a grouchy hot damn it's the
best replacement award this award goes
to the best replacement at this year's
Oscars and the winner is
the PricewaterhouseCoopers guy that
ruined Best Picture last year replaced
with this small plastic stand as it
turns out the whole Best Picture debacle
from last year could have been avoided
by using a 99-cent piece of plastic from
Michael's art supply I love plastic
doesn't text not distracted by
celebrities in fact some would even say
when talking about the future it's one
word plastics that's the reference to
the Graduate come on this next one is
the is JLo super tall or is Jodie Foster
extremely tiny award the award for that
moment that made us all asked is JLo
super tall or is like Jodie Foster
extremely tiny and the award goes to
Jennifer Lawrence presenting with Jodie
Foster which as it turns out j-law kind
of tall Jodie Foster little short that's
how that works
snikt this is the Logan award this award
goes to the biggest snub of the night
and the winner Daniel day-lewis for
costume design everyone knows winner
Marc Bridges was just a front for the
real phantom thread costume designer
Daniel day-lewis you think a guy that
method is gonna let someone else design
those clothes or was that designer
actually Daniel day-lewis in a bald cap
and makeup DDL greatest actor of our
time did you notice when that guy came
out on the jet ski
there was no shot of Daniel day-lewis
this here is the dgaf award the Oscars
are usually briefs
more occasion but some people just don't
give them this is the award for those
people and the winners Hollywood's elder
states women whether it was Eva Marie
Saint with the most casual of Hitchcock
name drops director Fred Hitchcock took
me to Bergdorf Goodman we're together we
show some of the beautiful wardrobe Rita
Moreno Tang going to the mic or Jane
Fonda riffing on the set orgasmatron and
Barbarella
these ladies had zero to give you know
what they were so badass I want to see
Jane Fonda Rita Moreno Eva Marie Saint
Helen Mirren and every other 50-plus
year old woman who was at the Oscars and
like a heist movie baby driver to ladies
night man what a night in showbiz what
do you think of the Oscars what you
think of the grouchy's what do we leave
out was there anything that blew your
mind and the show anything unexpected
let us know in the comments section I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
[Music]